so I'm Justin here with JC and we're
talking about dual universe an upcoming
MMO that is really heavy on the
technical side JC you guys are doing a
lot of different things with tech than
than we've seen at any other game before
that's right so there are basically two
fundamental technologies that we build
the whole game on the first is the the
new server technology that allows what
we call a continuous single shot
universe that means that everybody is
playing in the same world at the same
time and that there are no boundaries no
barrier no zones or any things like that
so you just walk wherever you want and
we make sure you know that that servers
are dynamically attributed where there
are more people so that you don't have a
fixed boundaries or things like that
the net result of that is that you can
imagine having things like a city
emerging in the game because of this
technology that allows potentially tens
of thousands of people gathering in the
same place and because of the other tech
which is about building and the fact
that you can modify the environment
which I can do right now if you want
like for here I'm going to put a cube
here or if I want I can actually dig
something right so this is a this is a
pre-alpha built this is there's nobody
else in the world right now because you
guys are still building with absolutely
so we are going to be completely
transparent on that what you see as
pre-alpha none of the assets is the
final assets with to work on them
we have also all almost all of the
gameplay to develop so we want to be
completely transparent we are not
setting a finished game if everything
goes well we hope to have a something
like a finished game by the end of 2018
so you see we're we're pretty early but
what we like is to communicate soon so
that we can have a lot of feedback from
the community which has already started
we have a lot of people giving us the
opinion and having very interesting
discussions with a forum open we also
started a community website you know
where people can actually start to
create organizations which other guilds
if you want it's the generalization of
what is a guild
and we already have I think more than
370 organizations declared so the
current is very active and we engage
with the community we discuss with them
I often go and talk to people online to
answer their questions so that's what we
want to do early on but because we have
those big claims you know about this
this technology and the single shard
world I think it's important also to
communicate quite early about the fact
that this technology exists and it has
work and it's not you know something
that we are attending actually the whole
point was that I started the company
when I got the technology working as a
prototype so that was the golden girl
moment so we start with technology and
we are now working on the gameplay with
a team of 25 people explains people from
the game industry so I'm not saying we
are now in the easy part of this but I'm
saying that we have we've worked on the
on the uncertain part the pub that was
not clear that could be done which is
the tech that allows this what you see
to happen in a gigantic world share by
potentially millions of people and let's
have a look at the world actually that's
how big it is so one planet go into
space Space Station's we will go there
soon let's go further away in the
universe can another planet here another
one that the position of the Sun
sometimes people say you know they are
very close to each other it doesn't make
sense I agree this is just a bit more as
I said pre-alpha retesting planets so we
just don't want to put them too far away
so we can actually play with them easily
this is not the final you know way
things are going to people but if you
look I'm going to slow down a bit this
is another planet that you saw in the
sky when we were there and this is the
original planet we came from see here
the space station is still there we have
for all practical purposes infinite you
know depth of our phone you can see
things they fade out of course but only
when they are becoming so small that it
doesn't matter
here it's still in development you see
load progressively it will go faster
when we are done with optimizations but
still it's pretty fast already and it
loads the the details as you get closer
to things that's how when the likes with
the load to display huge things and in
fact you know the the technology that
take care of planets is the same
technology that take care of orbital
stations or shape so that there is no
problem to have a ship that would be as
big as the planet of course the only
problem is that it's a kind of realistic
game so if you want to build something
you have to gather the resources first
and it's probably impossible to gather
that much resources and the time it
takes to actually deploy them and so on
to build something that would be like
like a planet but from a technology
point of view it's possible now what
could be done through the you know the
hard work of players only time will tell
yep there are some parallels of course
to no man's sky which came out recently
which also includes infinite planets and
in places to explore this seems like
you're going after something very
different yeah sometimes I say was a
joke like I know that there are two
common points with SN nomads sky we are
sci-fi ok and we have planets but apart
from that it's very very different
everything you see around you is
procedurally generated ok like in no
man's guide we hope to add also any
mores and things I don't know when maybe
not in the final release maybe in
expansions that we will have later so
I'm not you know promising that this
will be they are right away but yeah and
the long-term vision they could be
animals that would be really cool but
apart from that everything else you are
going to encounter I mean this space
station I was talking about this is
player made why it's made by us now of
course there are no players but you see
what I mean everything you will
encounter will be the result of players
creativity the the universe is going to
be very large but the known universe the
one you will be able to actually explore
I mean not explore but go to will be
limited by
how fast people are developing stargates
so there is a difference between you
know the existing universe and the
accessible or known universe that will
ok make the claim of how many planets do
you have a little bit pointless it's how
fast can you build stargates to explore
new systems and develop the industry
that is necessary for that also people
were exploring your systems for a reason
because it's costly to make a strong it
because requires plena fication and so
on that i explained that in them in some
post that we did recently so basically
if you if you have a standard to a given
system there's a high chance that there
will be people there and that you're not
bored because it's always different
because it's player-driven
look at the size of this station i I
would like to give you a sense of
proportion I'm going to slow down a bit
so I don't bump into it but let's go say
so you see by the way how it loads
progressively again this this is the key
to make this fluid no matter how big it
is I think I dropped a ship at some
point around here so this station is
absolutely gigantic it's 8 kilometres
long to be honest I'm not even sure that
that again how long have we take for
players to build that how many players
you need to have this it's it's probably
huge and ever let me just walk around so
you get a sense of how big this is I'm
actually running you see so the time it
takes to just go to the edge of this
little little thing here gives you an
idea so this this place is absolutely
huge
you mentioned the realism to this do you
also plan on like having planetary
gravity and having planets rotate and
things like that or yeah so gravity
definitely of course now actually if I
go a bit further from the station and
cut the god mode because of
I'm flying now as you can see it's not
what I mean you won't be able to do that
in a game but if I cut the god mode that
just fall on the planet that's actually
pretty easy to do the the other question
is we want to have day night cycle so
looking for example here's the Sun I can
move it and maybe I should take a bit of
altitude so you can see what it does I
will come back here later so it's a bit
laggy also because first we need to
optimize and also keep in mind that this
is currently running on a laptop which
is also running the server so in terms
of CPU it's it's kind of heavy but
anyway let's go frankly out of this this
in some ways is like EVE Online meets
minecraft see I'm sorry just to finish
on that yeah you have the potential
day/night cycle way is actually very
beautiful and when you are on the planet
you can have a nice sunset if you can go
there wherever so you get that and
that's it so the way we plan to do that
hopefully again is there is no guarantee
is that we would like to have the
planets rotate on themselves which is a
bit tricky because when you are on a
ship and you take off if you don't do
anything special and just make the
planet rotate the planets going to
rotate under your feet as soon as you
don't touch it right so the way we we
have to deal with that is to add a sort
of artificial force that will push push
to the ship alongside the planet so
we'll see if this is feasible but it's
probable that we are going to be able to
do it it's the Sun Oh like a real huge
Sun in the distance or is it just a
light source well let's go and see that
it seems that it's a real song that's it
so here we go it's a bit small but you
know it's not a big issue we can make it
bigger just to
you know say that this this is a real
simulation it's not the most difficult
part of this you know what is really
difficult is to have this planet again
remember this whole planet is completely
editable and if I want and if I have
time enough I could take this Montaigne
out of the picture by digging it out
that means also that there is multi
scale management of updates of the
landscape if you want that you are able
to see things either when they are taken
out or if they are built as as soon as
they are big enough so that they are
visible from space you've described the
game before it's like EVE Online media
minecraft yeah that's that's if I have
you know five seconds that's probably a
good way to start there is a bit of EVE
Online well let's say we start with
minecraft I would say there's a bit of
Minecraft because you can build things
but first of all it's not limited to
just cubes buddy as you have seen just
before and I can do that again here for
example you can have any any kind of
shape you want it can be smooth it can
be sphere it can be you can sculpt
basically matter the way you want so
that's that's one difference the other
big difference is that it's taking place
in an real MMO so if you it changes
everything every type of gameplay we can
talk about we could talk about combat we
could talk about industry or anything it
takes a lot of meaning when it's
happening in a in a real single-shot
world because people are part of a
collective story and what you do as an
impact on the on this story how the
world is going to evolve so mining so
minecraft like if you think that what
you watch you I'm sorry not mining
building so the minecraft side of things
if you think that your building can
actually be blueprinted and then we
produced into a factory then it takes
another scale in terms of meaning
because you might actually build a very
successful spaceship that will get you
know very successful on the market and
suddenly boom everybody is
using your spaceship and you're becoming
both famous and probably rich in the
game I was looking for the spaceship
actually it's there we're gonna fly in
it if you want yeah and as an MMO and
obviously player interaction is gonna be
an important part of this experience
exactly so because it's MMO all those
things take another dimension and so in
a second stage when there will be a
critical mass of players and enough
content that will be appearing in the
game I think we will enter into a even
lying evil nine like aspect where you
have all these markets and Industry and
Trade and politics and and territory
fight and control and all those things
that will that will start to to take
shape in this world so I think you know
the gameplay experience of the game will
probably evolve over time
bit more minecraft at the beginning if
you want us sort of and drawing towards
more even line type of things in the
future and ultimately I mean it will be
different from those two games it will
be probably a fairly different
experience so it's a quick way to
position the game but probably not
totally accurate ok so this this ship is
there so again you know as I showed in
other videos I mean it's completely
editable and by the way the space
station also can be edited so and not
only with cubes but I can add some
beautiful whatever so this this can be
the resolution also is depending on on
the size of the things you do for
example this ship as a smaller
resolution and space station here at
this point that's a bigger one we will
see if we make it adapted it would be
nice that you could have a super fine
resolutions in certain places but that
clearly is not for the first release but
something we might think about in the
long term in future let's get into this
ship so here I'm stepping in and it
flies so it can be completely built and
you transform the way you want and make
it look and behave the way you want
let's take a bit of speed and I'm a very
very bad pilot so I'm trying to you know
crash you know embarrassing way let's
maybe head for the planet again would if
you see if you crashed into the ship or
the planet does that deform the planet
or the ship or is that not no no we we
thought about that but actually the
decision is more to say it's better than
nothing happens just you just bump
against the thing because if you if you
do real damage we could do that but we
fear that people will start to build
ships as torpedoes and it will turn you
know fight into throwing things at each
other which is not exactly how we want
things to to go
besides also it will create probably
extra load on the servers for no good
reason
you know the way we envision combat is
by having a lock and fire mechanism that
will actually be coupled with you know
are more types and shield types and
types of weapons with specializations
plus kills and so on so it makes it
actually interesting for people to
specialize to get you know in to expert
level for for fighting with certain
types of things if we start to have
people using ships as weapons then I
think it will break a bit of the fun so
here we go oops sorry
learning I don't have my license anyway
so here you see below me the the level
of details are not loaded so it's a bit
coarse but let's stop here for example I
will just slow down and just land and
then step out of the ship here we go
boom that's it
and then the landscape repair so again
we optimizing this thing so we don't
want to break the immersion but you know
to make thing that big you have to also
make compromises and then try to you
know balance the load of everything but
you know you have this sense of
continuity we were there right still
there everything is it's a real world
that exists and I well I don't know
everything is because maybe perhaps some
other thing but I've not seen that in a
game so far and to make super exciting
because then I can start to invent my
story I can start to become a character
and become anything I want in the world
that is persistent that has meaning you
know that yeah that is evolving also so
I might be surprised but what but by
what I encounter in the game and I think
this is a surprise you know criteria is
something that I like very much like in
the real world the real world is
exciting because you never know what's
gonna happen you never know this of
course has to be balanced with game play
so that it doesn't go into total chaos
for example or Mad Max style so for that
we have been thinking a lot and probably
we are not done yet with all the
thinking on how to mitigate that for
example you see this huge thing over
there is can't go there actually it's
the ark ship so that's the the
mothership that you arrived in as you
colonists and everybody starts from
there and there will be a huge 20
kilometer safe area around that ship so
when you step out of this ship and you
arrive in the game again I mean this
this landscape is just placeholder I
don't consider this is there going to be
nicer we just printed this thing here so
what I won't say is that when you step
out of this you won't be sniped out by
some angry players there will be a safe
zone
and then you decide whether you want to
cross and go beyond that safe zone of
course all the interesting resources
will be on the safe zone so but you
could very well live inside the safe
zone and have a relatively peaceful game
experience still be contributing to the
game as a whole by you know acting on
the market the in-game markets will be
an incredibly important part to act as a
hub so that every player can be somehow
specialized in to things he likes and
sell what he likes and by what it
doesn't like basically you know like in
real life again so you could be in the
safe zone and being a relative safety
there will be other safe zones that will
be unlockable on other planets perhaps
on the same planet also we're thinking
for example on that point we are not
sure so that makes the profession of
Explorer even more interesting you might
discover an artifact that would become a
safe zone that will spawn another you
know intense economic area for example
people will be able to build their own
safe bubble bubble protection bubbles
there won't be indestructible like the
safe zone which are formerly impossible
to break but there will be very tough
and the more energy you put in them the
more the tougher they will be so suppose
you have an orbit a very important
market with a lot of goods traded there
you will make probably a lot of money
with the fees and you'll be able to
afford a hell of a bubble that will
require in proportion I mean to what is
inside the bubble and incredible amount
of firepower to break so plus the
warnings 48 hours of warning before
anything breaks and so there will be
ways out of the normal system to build a
relatively peaceful area if you put the
efforts together do you envision a story
for this world or is this kind of a game
that the player will create their own
story in their own mostly it's is the
second thing we want the story to unfold
according to what people are going to do
however
a backstory and we have already a short
story written by Alan DiMaggio with with
a great writer in France a very
well-known a bit less broad but because
it's work actually translated so I
recommend everybody to read it it's
really wonderful and it helped us to
work on on the backstory so that you
know we have a bit of explanation of why
we are here what happened before we will
use this backstory also to explain
certain things that you will encounter
in this in this world but mostly I mean
what will happen is going to be driven
by players it's not clear also how we
can make large-scale events in the game
because it has to remain interesting for
everybody if you make super villain at
some point at some place in the universe
once people have killed it it's a
persistent single-shot universe download
not going to respawn so it's not obvious
how to make stories in the classical
sense with that kind of game let me show
you maybe a bit of other things this
ship over there so a bit faster so this
is another example of a mid-range
mid-management is quite big ship again
loading progressively as you get closer
so you see the details appearing but
again this ship is completely editable
so just to clarify I'm going to go on
top of it and try to edit it so yeah one
thing also which is important to
understand is in a ship like this ship
you basically have two things you have
the the ground here all these things
which is made out of matter voxel-based
that can skirt in any way you want and
it's basically is the shape of your of
your ship for example and you have these
things here which I'm going to highlight
which are called elements and these are
static meshes that we do that we provide
as the basis
the gameplay and these elements are
craftable or you can buy them on the
markets and so on and the thing is that
they bring functionality so this is
obviously a weapon but there are other
things for radar for cockpit you saw one
before engines all sorts of engines and
so you bring functionality to you shape
which is a static you know form you
bring it by adding these elements to it
and then connecting them together
through scripting so you may script
actually in Lua for those who really
want but otherwise there are some
automatic configuration tools that we
look at your ship and do the scripting
for you so that it does the standard
thing that you expect but yeah for
people want to go a bit further imagine
working on some kind of small AI or I
don't know maybe autopilot so
autodefense think it will be really
possible we have also to balance the
automatic things so that it's somehow
always better to have human doing things
otherwise we end up with a game where
everything is automated so so here's you
know I'm getting inside the space
station so we bother to make something
inside it again I mean most of the space
station is empty but you see here this
this is made of elements just like the
the weapons that we saw or the cockpit
these are just decorative it's just to
look nice and to make a nice looking
interior but it's possible that you
I mean if you like this kind of corridor
instead of voxels you decide but people
are extremely gifted and what they do
with voxels I think will be will be
quite impressive as well so I don't know
if everybody is going to use that kind
of things so here oops
right on we enter the command room this
is a an example room that we made to
illustrate the concept of you know a big
room with a lot of screens this
queensday the display I mean there are
placeholders but the idea is that you
will be able to couple them with active
elements of your construct
that so they'll be able to display
useful information I don't know you can
imagine this filled with people managing
the request of docking on the station
doing a bit of background check on
whoever is trying to dock see whether
they are welcome or not
plus the weapon system the repair system
the whatever so but it's just to show
that there is an inside to do these huge
things that you you see it's obviously a
lot of work to make that so it can work
if the community is excited about the
possibilities and we have seen in
Minecraft that it happens right or in
other games maybe you know so uh
EverQuest landmark people got incredibly
creative so I am confident that we will
see pretty amazing things then why it's
a really cool concept it's I really look
forward to seeing what else you guys do
with it you know what me too and I think
you know I really want to play that game
so it's something that motivates us
every morning and it's it's beautiful
I like it so that's it awesome thanks so
much chasing it so a really interesting
first look at dual universe for us well
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
talk about it it's really cool thank you